we're all familiar with the base 10
number system or often called the
decimal number system where we have 10
where we have 10 digits 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 and now we've started to see that we
can have alternate number systems we can
have a base 2 number system known as the
binary number system where instead of 10
digits you only have 2 digits and each
place instead of being a power of 10 is
going to be a power of 2 now you can
imagine that we can keep extending this
we can extend to base 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 or
we could even go above 10 and what I
want to expose you what I want to show
you in this video is a fairly heavily
used number system that is larger than
or that has more digits than base 10 and
that is base 16 base 16 often called the
hexadecimal hexa decimal number system
and as you can imagine instead of having
only nine instead of only having 10
digits it is going to have 16 so what
are those digits going to be and as
we'll see instead of the places being
powers of 2 or powers of 10 they're
going to be powers of 16 so let's see we
could reuse the existing 10 digits from
the hexade from the decimal number
system so we can reuse 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 but then we're going to need to have 6
more digits and so the convention is to
use the the first six letters a b c d e
and f you might say these crazy these
are these are letters not numbers but
remember these are just arbitrary
squiggles of ink on a piece of paper
these are just arbitrary symbols that
we've grown to associate with things so
you've grown to associate this symbol
right over here with a t' thing with the
nut with the word 8 which you associate
with when you see that many objects and
so if you're thinking in hexadecimal
this isn't the letter A
that makes you want to say ah or the
letter B that makes you want to say buh
buh buh buh buh this is literally this
represents if you had ten things laying
around you would say I have a things
over there if you had eleven you'd say I
have B things over there twelve see
things
thirteen step saying I've thirteen you
get to AB D things there and instead of
saying I have fourteen you could say I
can I have a things there instead of
saying I have fifteen you could say I
have F things there now how does that
help well let's see if we can represent
the same number 231 or 231 in decimal if
we can represent that same number in
hexadecimal and I'll what I'll do is
I'll give you what the number is and
then I'll show you how we convert it
I'll show you the place value and I'll
show you how we convert it so 231 in
hexadecimal 231 and hexadecimal is the
number e
e7e seven and once again you're like
this looks crazy this looks like I'm
playing like battleship or something
what's ee7 this is a number and I would
say yes this is a number now you
remember
base 16 what are these place values
represent this first place represents 16
to the 0 power or still represents the
ones place this is the ones place this
is seven ones now what is this place
here represent well in base ten that was
10 to the first power and base two those
two to the first power so in base 16
this is going to be I'll leave those
there in base 16 this is going to be 16
to the first power so this is little
release I'll write well let me write out
the word this is literally 16s so this
is e 16 s plus seven ones and so let me
write that down
this is e 16 s e 16 s 16 s plus seven
ones that's what this number represents
now if we want to start rewriting this
we re conceptualizing it in our decimal
number system what is e 16 s well the e
if we think in decimal
he is he is 14 e is e is 14 and so this
is really you could really think of this
if you wanted in to think in decibels
this is 1416 s so what's 14 16s well
that's just the same thing as 14 times
16 14 times 16 is equal to 224 let me
actually do that same color so this
thing is going to be this right over
here is going to be 224 14 16 14 times
16 is 224 plus seven ones plus seven
ones
well 224 plus seven is going to give you
231 so hopefully you can appreciate you
can represent the same quantity in any
different in any of these different
number systems and any number that you
can represent in decimal you can also
represent that number in binary or in
hexadecimal or in base 3 or in base 60
or in base 31 whatever you want to do
and you might have noticed a pattern the
more symbols that we have so in base 16
you have 16 symbols the less place
values we need to represent the same
quantity and one way to think about it
is each of the places are containing
more information this is one of 16
characters while this over here is only
one of two characters this is one of 10
characters so the more symbols that you
have the more digits that you you could
put in each place the less places that
you need to represent to represent a
given quantity another way to think
about it is when you have a high base
like base 16
as you take powers of 16 what's the you
know the next place right over here
would be 16 would be 16 squared which of
course is 200 and will be 256 you're
clearly going to be able to represent
bigger numbers faster I guess you could
say or with less digits so it's just an
interesting thing to observe but
hopefully you're you get a kick out of
as much of a kick out of base 16 as I do
and it's actually useful this actually
is used if you look at
most web pages and if you look at the
actual code for the or I guess you could
say the format or the the formatting
like the HTML for the web page when they
specify colors they tend to specify it
in hexadecimal and that's because you're
specifying the colors the intensity of
the red the green or the blue between 0
and 255 and so two digits of hexadecimal
are perfect for that because if you
think about it what is what is F what is
F F what would this be if you were to
rewrite it in the decimal number system
and I encourage you to put too well
after this video is done I encourage you
to do that to figure that out on your
own
and if you really want to do something
fun let me give you another one try to
figure out what a f3 is and a this isn't
anything special I just wanted to give
you another interesting thing to work on